you have smooth skin and michou this
apollo xi mbiwa fairway in the meantime
I say them to the Luxembourg parliament
improvement will be the strong point of
our presidency each member state
alone will not be able to settle this
question
it is very difficult  the situation is
very difficult but we hope we
will end with time to find a
solution
facing no 700 migrants can be more
the worst immigration drama in the
mediterranean the film bilbo phanteks
operations center to move to saving
lives and self made in which  the enemy
is in his city
photo anne ministers it is a setting of
terrible scenes and place d'antoine
veyrat one knows this is not just sign
of god will finally gibbs
since several deaths we know that it is
a major subject  and so there we say to ourselves
we have seen it it is not something that we
discover and we cannot prevent
such tragedies cannot prevent such
tragic events and there it is
really an awareness
that everything we said she we said a
lot of things does not lead to the
results we expect, that is to
say to avoid these tragedies and contain the
migratory pressure
her victory the first decision that is
expected is to  strengthen the presence
of europe at sea but also in
external surveillance solidarnosc which
was like that from that moment
we saved more people
finally leave a
fundamental objective but we also saw
more and more people arriving and
routes  have changed since we moved from
the central Mediterranean to the
more eastern part but as soon as we
buy ambassadors yes you say this and
you beat nadal yes ninon louis xii the
rule that applies is that the  country
from which migrants arrive and
responsible for processing asylum applications,
but when you have thousands of
migrants,
you can clearly see the enormous burden that this
can represent for the countries of
first entry, so the i  dée fairly
quickly came to share this
responsibility wii will have May 10, 2007
offers ski hire mrs amos has experienced
this feeling that is major for 17 years
don't want it's ten years at the wheel there
are different stories especially
in the countries of  eastern europe
there is no great recent tradition in
any case of significant immigration this
openness is not
something natural and spontaneity german
eastern countries in societies  more
homogeneous there is fear scared of the
boudou dispute of the cattle breeds to be
coded there is no bus or keith hackett on a
daily basis
a migrant sometimes gives the impression of
choosing therefore one of the arguments of the countries
of eastern europe consists  to say
but these migrants do not want to come
to us which is not completely
false we saw this tension for a certain
moment I put all the ministers and
around the table his diplomat and
I told them give me a number  there is
a first decision a  with 48 people
in a context where the European Council
had said that it was necessary to decide by
consensus that there would be no
sudden decision with regard to the
Member States which had difficulties for
the relocation 40000 to be distributed
were blocked  at 33 here I am it was
already a signal on the voluntary basis
for me in any case we will
never be able to distribute more
Somali refugees end of saint patrick's day
but no we still have to start from the
beginning of September
alan this  5 year old boy who died
lying dead on the beach you were
already strong
we
had hope until maybe a
few hours before this meeting which
was at 3 o'clock we were able to
find a solution so on a
political basis saying then  at a certain point
I saw that it wasn't working and therefore
the presidency under the pressure of the
need to react we have to react we
cannot spend months discussing this
kind of proposal the treaty
gives us a tool that  i
'm the qualified majority so i said to some
of them ministers i said if it
doesn't pass i'm going to the vote
there were even people
from eastern countries at that time who cursed pass  to the
vote because for us it's
easier if it's through your that if we have to
find a consensus was not easy
fall and I was qualified so the
presidency says here we have to
tell each other and we'll see  the seven year olds know
that these are the rules of the game
it is not particularly pleasant
to be outvoted but they
must comply with them
if we go to the vote and take the
decision
it is a European law and  to no one you
can tell me I do not apply
the relocation is done once
the people the migrants have arrived
in what are called the West Indies, that is
to say places where they must be
registered to identify which  are the
real asylum seekers and those who
are more economic migrants
so it takes a lot of you  mps and then
sometimes the migrants refuse to be
registered do not want to go through these
areas serhat balci when you have smagghe
the belt all styles then is
a tube beat them all right thing as you
kill munich
all come to the afghans a relocation
prosys not far  places welcomed on the
left the ex big o queen sofia there is a
lot of money being made with
criminal organizations in
really extremely shocking conditions
so the smugglers tell them be
careful do not get recorded
we should explain the
relocation what it is it's
not putting them on a plane and in a camp
no but it's giving them a chance
to be able to make rice in a country
of the european union we have analyzed
the people who are  threatened in
their existence in the countries in
situation of war of conflict therefore the
people who are not entitled to
receive asylum normally must
return to their country of origin  ine
there were days when month of november
when there were arrivals
twenty thousand people came
just by the spurs cc it's terrible
greece is afraid that you are huge
refugee camps not relocatable and not
returnable  come together so
angles this is a fear that has
always been explained to me pn i understand i
understand
ep
e
i love you
criticizing by millions except
potential refugees trying to reach the
rope est light of the most jean crèche
est pas au  top gun control in style
the plates of the 30s rieter is who the cross country skier
coming ball said to me
reinhart mitschek de l'ast falls
grant's pentagon former big cop
all for a woman elin and our
relationship with turkey i hope we
will be able to build it you have a little
more confidence
sometimes it's difficult that's clear
maybe I am but also for us
yes we get up with the mood for life in
motion 5 on sound and nobody is the key
to be  to win it
works sad  laugh the two tweets or not
expect in one to get on board the
boats remains stable
there it is as if all this timing of the
migrations 10 km flow or eye to the
variators which govern a tanker
rignault reacts ease of tribe and
the  yonne it's clear to me the 3
billion we don't give them to the
Turkish president or to May 1
Turkish government structure we give them so that
two million Syrian refugees
can have a prospect of having a
job in turkey and australia  100 km
ice road name fu panda 2
president recipes products
we have a common good which is
free movement inside
disk space it can
only work if the external borders of
the european union are controlled but
if this control is not properly
ensured everyone loses
and therefore we must help the countries to
properly control the external borders
second European port because such a good
case because  it's not a
me and you drop in hors grade agency
richard a frontex aubry you have
to realize what its chains it's
the common market it's free
movement it's the europe of the citizen
all that is  will collapse if everyone is gone
and their one shots
once gone I won't come back to
this crisis there are
very, very strong national political issues
in almost all the
states all the heads of state are clearly seen they have a
personal commitment
they  have at the national level
pressure difficulties questions they
have to respond to public opinion
we
these are issues that
directly concern citizens and therefore I
would say that they have a certain impact on
the way in which elections are won
or  lost in terms
of all-inclusive themes at
council level there was still
very, very strong support and I must also say that
at country level on the telephone we
could still talk to all the people even
those who  i had another position
to